number two photos can be doctored they
could have put Bruce Wayne's head on
that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham to
hang out in Star City recently No
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie you've
probably seen the news they are
officially doing a Batwoman TV show at
the CW set to debut I believe next year
because it's still in the script phase
right now they still have not cast their
Batwoman actress so I'll explain what's
going on because now a lot of people are
like wait a minute does this mean that
arrow really is going to be in its last
season and this will just replace that
or is this gonna replace Supergirl so no
worries I'll explain everything but if
you're finding me for the first time
it's Comic Con week be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so if you have no idea what's
going on
Kate Kane Batwoman is going to debut
during the four-way cross over later
this year in the air overs now remember
we do have black lightning that's
technically the fifth arrowverse show
but they said that it's not connected to
the air overs so there's really still
just the four as you would imagine
because Batwoman is debuting during a
arrowverse crossover it is officially
being pitched is an arrow verse show so
yes we just need to say the obvious
arrow isn't its seventh season ratings
are declining on pretty much all the
shows a little steadily so I think
they're hedging their bets and they want
a really big character that sort of
checks all the boxes for the demographic
that the CW is looking to get they want
a strong female lead they want dark tone
and they want an LGBT character so in
the way that arrow and Black Lightning
or the darker grittier air / shows I
think bad woman is just the newest
bullet in that chamber I know a lot of
you are asking for 13 episodes instead
of 23 so they can do quality over
quantity I think now that we're moving
into the digital age of television like
people are getting their shows more and
more from digital devices than they are
from traditional TVs the CW network has
started to adapt to the way their
audience is consuming their television
programming so I think with a little bit
of help from Netflix on international
distribution like they do with some of
the other brand new CW TV shows that
Greg Berlanti has done 13 episodes is
totally doable the business stuff is
kind of boring but Warner Brothers in CW
the people that are responsible for
making these shows don't make their real
money on the series till they sell to
syndication and that doesn't happen till
they have a giant block of episodes so
you can see why in the past
why they would just crank out 23:24
episodes of season because the faster
you hit that big syndication number the
faster you can make money on the series
but if you live outside the United
States you probably be getting some of
the more recent shows on Netflix they
become the international partner that
distributes all the shows it's actually
fairly efficient and I think that's also
how they're gonna do the Titans TV show
they give them more money up front so
they don't need to produce as many
episodes which is why you can get away
with 13 episodes per season but the big
stuff if you're not familiar with the
Kate Kane Batwoman character they'll
probably do a version of her origin
story maybe she'll already be Batwoman
when she shows up during the four-way
crossover then maybe when they actually
get to the first episode of the Batwoman
TV series they'll do the arrow thing
where they have a couple flashbacks that
explain her backstory they haven't
confirmed that yet I think they'll have
run of the Batman comics in terms of
characters that they use unless the
characters are in a movie getting ready
to be in a movie or they're already
earmarked for another TV series like
Titans so like I don't expect Dick
Grayson to be a character on the
Batwoman TV series if you haven't been
reading the comics recently Batwoman is
actually getting ready to be kicked out
of the bat family by Batman because
she's straight up killed Clayface so I
think one of the important things to
remember is is the tone in what her
character is like I could have handled
these c-listers on my own dressing like
a bat doesn't make you a hero it just
makes you a target
and using a gun makes you just like them
I don't think that the CW series is
gonna make any dramatic alterations to
that I think they want a really dark
gritty badass female led series and that
is the bat woman character the opposite
end of that spectrum is Supergirl so
like imagine how silly they get on the
Supergirl TV show I don't think they're
gonna shoe in any of that into the
bat woman TV series I think they're
gonna let it be as hardcore as they want
it to be then if they want a character
like that on the series they'll let
somebody cross over like they'll have a
Supergirl bat woman crossover so next
big thing I know you're all wondering
which earth is she gonna be on because
Stephen Amell name-drop Bruce Wayne on
arrow so we know there is Gotham Bruce
wayne/batman
on this earth we haven't seen him yet
and I don't know if we're ever gonna see
him but if she's gonna debut during the
four-way crossover then Supergirl is
gonna be the first episode of that so
would that mean that she debuts on
supergirls earth 38 how's this gonna
work is she gonna be from a different
earth so her stories will be largely
self-contained and she won't reference
all the stuff that's happening on the
other TV shows all the time but if they
decided to put her somewhere else I
think it'll be fine flash is the key to
the multiverse he can port to other
dimensions as fast to see what Cisco is
the key to that there's even a point in
the comics where he gets powerful enough
to phase between universes on his own
speaking of which we actually do have a
preview of the first episode of the
flash I'll do a video about that later
today it's just that the Batwoman TV
series is actually a pretty big deal so
I wanted to do that video first crib
notes are is that she went to West Point
she's a total badass she was training to
be part of the military they found out
that she was a lesbian kicked her out of
school she became a bit of an arrow do
well party girl in Gotham got picked up
for speeding by Renee Montoya they got
into a relationship later outside a club
she got mugged fought off her attackers
then Batman shows up and it gives her
the idea to be a vigilante because she
has the skill she has the training to be
a vigilante but she hadn't hit rock
bottom yet she didn't have the drive
with a desire to make herself better or
make the city better or help people out
so that's when she chose to became the
bat woman her father because he's a big
military man who was responsible for
armoring her
and giving her all her weapons so that's
why Batman is so surprised when he sees
her like why are you running around
wearing my symbol it's because Batman
did kind of inspire her but all of her
gear came from the military through her
father so I think it's pretty easy to
assume that her father is gonna be the
Quentin Lance or the Harrison wells type
characters that helps her out it remains
to be seen if they would ever turn him
into a villain but in the comics series
her military father is mostly her ally
but that doesn't mean that the TV show
couldn't play with their allegiances
because it's a pretty big trope in
superhero series that the military is
usually in opposition to what super
heroes one but season one I think is
just about her becoming the Batwoman
character in establishing who her
recurring characters are like who's
gonna be helping her out if Renee
Montoya is gonna be a recurring
character and that will be her
relationship or they'll build up to that
relationship and what they're gonna do
with the rest of the bad family because
you can't be Palin around Gotham City
all the time without explaining where
Batman is so they'll have to find some
way of referencing Bruce Wayne I think
they're totally free and clear to
mention Bruce Wayne but ask for Batman
showing up in a genuine bat suit I think
that might be off-limits but if they
were able to do Superman on the
Supergirl TV show then I wouldn't be
surprised if they work up to a genuine
Batman appearance in a bat suit
eventually maybe not first season maybe
like second third fourth season
disciplines on how successful the TV
series is so let me know in the comments
series is wide open what do you want
them to do with it do you want it to be
a super hardcore do you want her to be
on supergirls earth do you want them to
have a lot of crossovers do you want her
to be on earth one so she can crossover
with flash and arrow the flash video
that I'm working on will post a little
bit later today we have a better look at
Nora's costume and some big twists for
the first episode of the flash so I'll
do a preview video in a little while
while you wait for everything click here
for my new Aquaman preview and click
here for brand new Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching happy Comic Con
week I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]